hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff and buy the good stuff
I mean Game seven of the 1972 World
Chess Championship match between body's
facility of its passkey and Robert James
Fisher now if you've been following the
Bobby Fischer story so far you know that
he he won the intra zonal tournament in
palma de mallorca in 1970 then he
continued to win the candidates matches
against the time anova Larson and Tigran
Petrosian
lastly in Buenos Aires now he faces
Boris Spassky he lost the first two
games first one he was due to that
blunder of the bishop well okay he could
have perhaps saved it later but doesn't
really matter and Game two he lost
because he didn't show up and then out
of the four next games he won three and
a half points out of four
so only one draw for spots key and three
games were owned won by favor so this is
a game seven and even though the result
is only three and a half to two and a
half in Fischer's favor the important
part is that out of the four previous
games Fischer took three and a half
points so Spassky really has to do
something about this hence the quote
above the board as this is a Spassky
someone opinion about this game so who
will left it off at Game seven
Spassky applauded his opponent under
under brilliant victory and Fischer of
course as usual celebrates alone this
time he he went bowling up until 5 a.m.
and there's a very interesting story
about the beginning of the seventh game
Spassky said that if Fischer has such a
nice and fancy chair that he would also
enjoy a fancy chair so they had a chair
flown over from New York I was a very
fancy chair it costed almost $500 some
four hundred and seventy dollars and now
Spassky could swivel in his chair as the
Fischer did very often and one Fischer
fan didn't really think that it was this
was it could have a negative
psychological effect on Fischer
so Fischer and this Fischer spent stole
the chair as that was especially
delivered for Spassky and he hit it but
fortunately for Spassky the chief
arbiter Letarte shmita was able to
recover it
and the chair was a place for Spassky
decision before game 7 started so all is
well and this time or after
even though Spassky used efore in his
1979 World Chess Championship match
against even petrosyan last time he used
that against Fischer was some 12 years
to go so here we have E 4 by Spassky and
he said that due to the fact that he
lost out of the of the other previous 4
games to 3 and 1/2 points he can't keep
avoiding Fischer's pet line against
efore and now he wants he really wants
to fight so official replies C 5 and of
course we will have a night off on the
board as for more than 4 for over a
decade Fischer was considered the top
authority on undenied earth Knight to f3
d6 d4 C captures Knight captures knife
to f6 Knight to c3 and a6 we do have
denied her from the board and the
Spassky allows Fischer to go for his pet
line Spassky chooses the sharpest move
Bishop to g5 e 6 we have f4 and here it
is Queen to b6 Fischer goes for the
poisoned pawn variation it really
doesn't get any better than this last
person to allow Fisher to go for this
Queen to b6 poisoned pawn variation was
Parma in the tournament of piece that
was played in Rome in Zagreb in 1970 and
Fischer won that game very nicely
excellently if I do say so
Queen to d2 of course Spassky offers the
B to pawn Queen captures and now Knight
to b3 this is the first time someone
actually plays Knight to b3 against
Fischer
the idea is point to a 3 and then
trapping the Queen with rook to a2 so
there are several ways you can counter
this Fischer immediately gets the Queen
out of this trap and here we have Bishop
to d3
Fischer simply continues we have Bishop
to e7 Spassky castles and now h6
asking Spassky what do you want to do
with this Bishop so if you capture on f6
for example Bishop captures Bishop
captures and now e5 d captures on e5 and
after ninth to e4
it seems like white is building up some
sort of an attack but after Knight to c6
it's very hard to find a way for white
actually to continue the attack so after
h6s possibly decides to sacrifice upon
we have Bishop to h4 offering d4 pawn
and Fischer grabs it
we have Knight captures on e4 now
opening our discovered attack against
this Bishop Knight captures on e4 and
now Bishop captures on h4 and here a lot
of a lot of different ideas do seem
possible
for example yeah we have to check out
the option of this very interesting
Knight captures on d6
for example if you play this Knight
captures on d6 Queen captures on d6 and
now if you're hoping to win the Queen
with Bishop to b5 check because you've
opened up a discovered attack towards
blacks Queen King to e7 simply defends
the Queen your queen is now under attack
the bishop is under attack on b5 and the
white will just feel silly for
sacrificing the knight on d6 on the
other hand one option that Spassky as he
definitely prepared this line he did
check out the Bishop to b5 move but then
after a capture some b5 yes now you can
start to the attack with Knight captures
on d6 as now the Queen is already
guarding the night but now after King to
e7 as now the rook is guarding the
bishop if you go to a faith then Knight
can capture Bishop Knight captures on b5
attacking the Queen and now you have to
go Queen to a6 to prevent the Queen from
checking the King on d6 so the queen is
now guarding the d6 square but now comes
Queen to b4 check and after King to d8
rook does come to d1 would check but now
nice to d7 and it seems that black
defended successfully so although it is
a very fierce attack as poss he doesn't
feel like it's worth going for so first
he plays f5 he sacrifices yet another
pawn to perhaps make this attack happen
just a little bit faster and Fischer
doesn't mind he grabs yet another pawn
he captures on f5 and now if you try
something like Queen to f4 and say that
ok if F if F captors on e4 I can capture
on f7 also I'm attacking your Bishop on
h4 simply Bishop to e7 and you have to
do something about this Knight black
will save
castle and all is well for Fisher so
after this it captures on f5 and now
Spassky says that now it's a completely
different story that will open up the
file now Bishop to b5 is definitely a
thing and he does play it but Fischer
simply captures the bishop a capture
some b5 Fischer takes everything Spassky
offers him
we have Knights the d6 check and here
comes Fischer's brilliant defensive idea
now the same idea King to e7 doesn't
really work for black guys now D file is
open now you can actually capture on b5
Knight captures on b5 and after Queen to
a6 Queen to b4 check similar as in the
previous variation but after King to f6
now Queen captures on h4 this comes with
check and now g5 doesn't really do
anything for us Queen can remain over to
d4 with check so here King to g6 and now
after a for defending the knight you
would win the piece back and with the
black being so underdeveloped it would
be a very hard position to vote to hold
for black so instead after this Knight
to d6 check Fischer doesn't go King to
e7 and guards the bishop with the rook
rather he plays King to f8 he allows
Spassky to capture the bishop the piece
back and he offers Spassky to go for a
worse endgame and after considering what
to do here ideas like rook to a rookie
one if you just happily continue
sacrificing it doesn't really work yes
you do have the threat rook to the 8th
rook to e8 but simply bushel captures
rook captures and now Bishop to e6
blocking off drugs path 3/8 and black is
completely winning now
so Spassky doesn't find a better move he
has to go for this slightly worse NBA
Knight captures on c8 and now Fischer
simply plays Knight to c6 a nice
developing move opens up an attack
against Spassky tonight and there really
isn't a way for Spassky to actually
continue this attack although for the
moment Fischer's King is slightly odd on
f8 and it will take him some time to
play g6 King to g7 and bring the other
look into the game but there's no way
for Spassky to actually prevent this so
it seems Fischer defended its only move
17 and again it seems that it will be
Fischer who will be playing for the win
in game 7
we have night back to the six spots he
has to bring the night back to safety
rook to d8 pinning the knight also this
comes with a double attack on the night
and now comes Knight captures on b5 here
Spassky actually wouldn't mind if
Fischer captures the Queen for example
look captures Queen captures Knight
captures Queen on a three the rook is
under attack rook to d5 and Spassky will
try to hold this with the white pieces
but Fischer isn't interested in a queen
trade he goes Queen back to e7 Spassky
screen is still under attack we have
Queen to f4 attacking the bishop g6
preparing King to g7 a king to g7 and
bringing the rook into the game and here
we have a four by Spassky and here is
the first moment where Fischer takes a
better position and doesn't treat it as
perhaps as carefully carefully as he
should have but he did win three and a
half points out of the previous four
games so perhaps it made him a little
bit hasty but he plays Bishop to g5 here
there's always time for that you don't
have to rush anything
better yet was king to g7 and then bring
your rook into the game and then black
can play anything he wants white doesn't
have a way for pushing for anything here
and Fischer says that he was very
unimpressed with how he played this game
but okay butter up to g5 attacks past
his Queen Queen moves to c4 and now we
have Bishop to e3 check King to h1 and
now f4 a very unpleasant position for
white as this Bishop Bishop and pawn on
f4 are really preventing Spassky from
using the rooks but all of this was
playable even if you first play it came
to g7 brought the other rock into the
game and then with all of your pieces
developed only then push for advantage
because for now we still have an
undeveloped rook on h8 g 3 by Spassky a
very nice move that hopes to break open
these pawns and now F captures on g3
although possible you don't want to move
like rook a to e1 so instead Fischer
simply plays g5 protects the f4 pawn we
have rook a to e 1 by Spassky now the
rooks are very nicely placed in the
center of the board and now come
Queen to b4 Fischer offers offers a
trade of Queens and he says that he will
enjoy this superior ending and push for
a win here queen capture son before we
have night capture son before and now
comes rogue to e2 defending the c2 pawn
and how does Fischer proceed here here
finally Fischer plays King to g7 he
prepares to bring the other rook into
the game but again as he mentions later
I move like Knight to c6 would have been
much better blacks pretty much blacks
only weakness here is the b7 pawn and
the way for whites to attack it is
Knight to a5 so what Knights the c6 you
would prevent this and black would have
an easier game and the white wouldn't
really have a good move as this Bishop
is really a monster here controlling all
of these dark squares you can't play
rough to d2 to confront a black stroke
on d8 of course you cannot go to d1
because nothing is guarding it and d1 it
would be a very hard position to play
for Spassky
but again Fischer goes for King to g7
and now comes Knight to a5 immediately
Spassky goes after this pawn
b6 and now nice to see for again
attacking the pawn and b6 but also now
attacking the bishop on e3 Knight to d5
guarding the pawn ended the bishop
Knight C to d6 and now this knight on d6
is also a monster so you do have to do
something about this here Fischer
decides to go after it Bishop to c5
attacking the knight and now we have
Knight to b7 attacking the bishop here
and here was most likely the most
critical moments in the game where
Fischer can actually go for a win with
with a certain move but feel free to
pause the video here and how would you
treat this position it doesn't win the
game like instantly but it's it's the
weight definitely the way to go it's
what the licorice mentions in his book
and Fischer also said says that well he
was overall a very unimpressed with his
game buddy I feel free to pause the
video here and give it give it your best
I'll give it a couple of seconds as
usual for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are really
excellent the end game player and for
those of you just wanna enjoy the show
the idea is nice to e3 your rock is
under attack yes but you will also
attack spassky's rook and now you have
several options here the most important
thing is if you move the rook then f3 is
coming you can't block this because the
rook to d1 will eventually result in
checkmate after you give up both rooks
then ro captures on f1 will be checkmate
on the other hand after this night to
eat remove you have to play something if
you play Knight captures here and then
simply Knight captures on f1 grabbing
the look back and now your knight is
attacked here after we move it tonight -
b7 f3 is coming attacking the rook you
have to move the rook rook to e1 now
comes 9th to e3 and now f2 and f1 wins
the game last option after 92 e3 is
moving the rook while still keeping
control of the first rank for example
look - a one but still f3 is coming
rock - f - now first attacking the f3
pawn but now g4 defending it and now
white will face a lot of nasty
discoveries here if you don't grab the
Bishop so Knight captures on c5 b
captures on c5 and after came to g1 rook
h2 8 and now Fischer position is is
definitely winning here this was one one
such idea but here a Fischer instead
goes for rook to c8 he moves his rook
out of this very very important opened
e-file and Spassky really makes use of
this a small leap of hope c4
he attacks the knight on d5 first place
9 3 3 but now it's a different story now
nice - e3 is not so powerful because
here everything is the same but now
simply rook to f3 there is no more rook
on the edge to deliver checkmate we have
Luke to D 1 we have Knight captures on
c4 by Fischer but now comes pawn
captures on f4 pawn a pawn to g4 and now
comes rope to d3 so Spassky was able to
mess up Fischer so strong pawn structure
he had a very nice pawn chain here also
the poem was afraid to come to f3 and
now Spassky controls the only to open
files on the board see file is also open
but
there's a you know it's pretty crowded
there so we have h5 by Fisher h3 by
Spassky enter now comes the night to a5
challenging the strong night on B 7 and
this has already moved 36 so we are
reaching time control it's very
important that you and that you reach it
- with a good position we have Knight to
d6 is passkey avoids the trade on a5 and
here we have Bishop captures on d6
Knight captures on d6 and now as Fischer
would this maneuver moving the Knight to
a5 and capturing and d6 Fischer opens up
the 3rd open file for his rook so rook
to c1 this comes with Chuck King to g2
and this is move 39 so both players need
to make one more move to reach time
control it's baskis move what do you
play here here
[Music]
sorry it's Fischer's move first and
Fischer decides to go for Knight to c4
so he says spassky's knight on these
sixes is a too strong of a piece we have
to trade it and while nightcap while it
is possible to play something like
Knight to f5 Spassky instead goes for
Knights to e8
this comes with check and here came to
g6 is played so this is the 40th move
time control has been reached and now
spot he has to make one more move to
reach adjournment and he has to decide
which move he will seal so they can
analyze it over the course of the entire
night and here after considering all of
the possibilities as Pascal decides to
go for h4 and he spent 45 minutes on h4
before actually sealing it and this is
where the game was adjourned and now the
players of course ended their seconds
were analyzing it and this is something
I will also mention for example I'm like
rook to d5 was also an idea but then
Spassky says that this isn't really a
threat Fischer will simply play f6 and
everything is everything is fine for
black but it's after this h4 move
everyone was very impressed with this
move as poss he really had to figure a
lot of things out as you'll see here
it's something Nicolai Kroger spassky
second dimensions in his diary here it
was after the game was adjourned it was
a really an intense battle of of seconds
like you had you had to analyze it six
hours over the course of the entire
night to be able to prepare for the game
tomorrow because officially still better
here h4 is a brilliant move but black is
still better and Spassky really cannot
afford to lose another game and everyone
was analyzing the for the entire night
to figure out the best continuations for
white but Kroger's mentions that
although Fischer did have a second his
second was a William Lombardi
but Fischer always first analyzed it for
himself
and only when he was finished analyzing
himself only then he would he consult a
Lombardi for a foreign opinion also a
very interesting piece of information
here Fischer goes f6 after it was
continued tomorrow if he goes for
something like King to a5 this is also
something Spassky had to see very nicely
and also why h4 was very important h4
was very important because it covers g5
now after nights the g7 Fischer would
have to repeat moves he would have to go
back King to g6
because if he captures here then of
course you get rook to d4 and this is
checkmate
you can see that all of the squares
around the black King are covered and
the h4 point nicely covers the g5 square
so instead after h4 official goes for f6
and here we have rook to e6 with a
double attack against DF 6 pawn rook to
c2 check we have King to g1 and now
comes King to f5 now King to f5 is
different it will not result in black
being checkmated because the king is now
on g1 also possible was instead of this
game to a5 a nice exchange sacrifice via
Road captures on e8 Spassky and his team
analyzed this thoroughly Fischer also
says that he analyzed it and he didn't
see that it leads to anything but really
you have to see that after rook captures
nice to d2 now this night is coming to
f3 and it will be a very nice position
for black
for example rook to e2 nice to f3 with
shirt King moves and now rook the c-4
attacking both the f4 pawn and DA for
pawn so you can't really allow black to
capture either of this pawn these pawns
as we have to capture the night rook
captures you bring you give up you give
back the exchange G captures now comes
King captures on f3 and now came to f5
attacking the f4 pawn we have looked to
be two rook captures with check King
moves rope to g4 check King to h3 and
now rook captures on a four rook
captures on b6 and now the problem is
this will be a draw in the end as
there's no way for for black to actually
break through here if you try to move
the King rook here King to g2 and you
can't bring your King closer because you
have to keep an eye on the f6 pawn but
yeah a very important idea and they
really thought Fischer might might go
for this so they spent a lot of time
analyzing this but there will be a link
in the description below to the whole
Nikolaj Gragas diary so feel free to
check it out there are a ton more
variations there for you to enjoy
I thought about including all of the
ones he mentions but it would it would
really make like an hour of a video but
for those of you who are interested in
some supreme vast knowledge you know
feel free to go for it King to a5 by
Fischer
now the same idea I will not leave the
checkmate as we've already mentioned
Knight to g7 check King can now capture
on f4 there's no King on g2 now comes
rook to d4 check and now Fischer brings
this King or over to g3
seems like a very nice position for
black if Fischer can get one move look
to c1 check it could very well lead to
checkmate
but Spassky had this whole position
analyzed over the course of the entire
night Knight to f5 check was played we
have King to f3 and the now comes rook
to e4 and now the important thing is
that now rook to c1 will lead the King
to h2 and there
really no way to push for anything with
black here safer dead playbook the c1
came to h2 was played after rook to c2
check kink the g1 was played and it was
in this position on move 49 that the
players agreed to a draw it's very
interesting because bus spent so much
time preparing that h4 moved to seal he
only had like less than 20 minutes on
the clock for the entire adjourned game
until until move 60 where another time
control is reached so here there's
really no way to push for advantage even
the official tries to push for advantage
even he could get checkmated for example
if you try something like King G Rho G
to check King moves and now rook here to
threaten checkmate
it would actually be Fisher who'd get
checkmate
for example rook F for check King G -
nice - g3 check King III rook F to e4
check King f3
rook to d3 check nine three three
blocking and now rook rook D captures on
e3 with checkmate so of course you know
that was nothing like this happened
after King - g1 they agreed to a draw
and here fast Spassky said that this is
the first game where he showed his
fighting spirit and indeed challenging
Fisher which efore to play his favorite
line had the poisoned pawn variation of
the Sicilian truly an amazing line the
this variation will be repeated once
more in this match and it will really be
an amazing game but we're gonna get back
to that so that's that's a game 7 I do
hope you enjoyed it like I said a lot of
useful links will be in the description
below also I will add a nice a nice half
half an hour documentary also in the
description below it's called chess a
state of mind - check it out it's really
enjoyable and check out all of the
useful links so yeah now I do hope you
enjoyed it I do hope you're enjoying the
Bobby Fischer series so far and I would
like to thank John Armani Marshall
Andrade Brian calling Alex Las Kobe and
James Jeffery for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my preview
videos CR think'll for watching and I
will see soon
most likely with game eight of this
Spassky Fischer match thank you all and
I'll see you soon